MAYBE THEY WILL, BUT KEEP IN
MIND, THEY SAY THE SAME THING
ABOUT MANUFACTURING JOBS 30
YEARS AGO.
DAVID HAS DONE A LOT OF RESEARCH
ON THE SUBJECT
THINGS ARE COMING ON.
IT'S CLEAR THAT THERE IS A MALE
EMPLOYMENT AND WAGE CRISIS AND
IT'S CLEAR THAT'S DRIVING FAMILY
DISSOLUTION IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
COUNTRY WHICH IS WHY WE ARE
SEEING SAME SOCIAL PATHOLOGIES.
IT'S ABOUT WAGES.
WHY AREN'T OUR POLICYMAKERS
RESPONDING TO THIS?
>> FIRST OF ALL, WE HAVE TO
AGREE THAT IT'S A CRISIS.
IMAGINE 90 LAMBEAU FIELD, 90
STADIUMS FULL OF MEN MISSING IN
ACTION FROM OUR WORKFORCE.
WE HAVE A CONCEPT OF A PROBLEM.
OBVIOUSLY THIS IS A TERRIBLE
EFFECT ON MEN, MEN ARE FAR MORE
LIKELY TO WANT TO WORK AND
THEREFORE FAR MORE LIKELY TO BE
DEPRESSED WHEN THINGS AREN'T
WORKING OUT.
IF WE CAN AT LEAST AGREE ON
THOSE BASIC FACTS, WHICH WE KNOW
FROM A MYRIAD OF STUDIES, I
THINK IT'S A GOOD STARTING PLACE
THINK IT'S A GOOD STARTING PLAC
PLACE.
>> Tucker: THERE SEEMS TO BE
RESISTANCE ON THE PART OF
POLICYMAKERS, EVEN TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE PROBLEM AS IF,
AT THIS IS JUST A GUESS, IT'S
SOMEHOW AN ATTACK ON WOMEN TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THERE IS A MALE
EMPLOYMENT CRISIS.
POLITICS SEEM TO PLAY A ROLE.
>> IT DEFINITELY PLAYS A ROLE
AND SO DOES OUR CULTURE AND OF
COURSE, THAT'S SILLY.
YOU CAN CARE ABOUT WOMEN AND YOU
CAN CARE ABOUT MEN.
FEMINISM TAUGHT US THAT WHAT
HURTS ONE SEX HURTS US ALL.
IF WE CAN TAKE SOME OF THE
GENDER POLITICS IRONICALLY OUT
OF A DISCUSSION THAT'S HAPPENING
TO MEN, PERHAPS WE CAN START TO
TREAT THEM AS PEOPLE.
>> Tucker: THE CONVERSATION
APPEARS TO HAVE MOVED FROM WHAT
YOU JUST SAID, AND ACKNOWLEDGES
THAT THEY THRIVE WHEN EACH IS
THRIVING TO A ZERO-SUM
UNDERSTANDING WHERE MY LOSS IS
YOUR GAIN AND VICE VERSA.
WHEN DID THAT CHANGE?
SPEAK OUT YOU COULD ARGUE WITH A
FEMINISM THE 1970s, BUT THAT'S
A LONG TIME AGO.
A HALF-CENTURY AGO NEARLY AND I
WOULD JUST SAY IT'S POLITICALLY
INCORRECT TO TALK ABOUT THE
CRISIS AMONG MEN IF YOU READ A
LOT OF LIBERAL PUBLICATIONS.
CAN YOU IMAGINE IF WE APPLY THAT
TO OTHER GROUPS THAT ARE
EXPERIENCING UNIQUE DOWNSIDES OF
OUR ECONOMY?
WE HAVE A CRISIS AND I THINK WE
CAN GET PAST -- THE HARDEST PART
WILL GET PAST THE POLITICS.
IT INCREASES THE RATES OF
DEPRESSION IN THESE MEN,
DIVORCE, THEY GO TO CHURCH LESS,
THEY CERTAINLY REMOVE THEMSELVES
FROM SOCIETY.
AT THE DOWNWARD CYCLE.
THEY WATCH MORE TELEVISION, JUST
A DIRE SITUATION.
>> Tucker: THERE IS A
RELUCTANCE TO HAVE SERIOUS
CONVERSATION PLURALISTS, THERE
NEVER DEBATED MORE.
THERE'S TECHNOLOGY ON THE
HORIZON THAT WILL DISPLACE
MILLIONS OF AMERICAN WORKERS
DISPROPORTIONATELY MEN, I NEVER
HEAR THE IMPLICATIONS OF THAT.
>> IT'S TREATED LIKE A NATURAL
DISASTER AND IT'S BEEN TREATED
LIKE A NATURAL DISASTER FOR
DECADES AND IT'S INFURIATING.
OF COURSE, AUTUMN IS AGE AND OF
THE INDUSTRIALIZATION IS A
CRISIS, BUT MAN MADE DECISIONS
THAT IMPACT OF THIS CRISIS AND
THEY STILL DO.
AS WE MOVE FORWARD WITH
AUTOMATION, WE HAVE TO CONSIDER
THE DOWNSIDE THE GOOD OF IT WILL
BRING.
>> Tucker: THEY TREAT MARKET
CAPITALISM LIKE RELIGION RATHER
THAN A USEFUL ECONOMIC SYSTEM,
BUT WE CAN'T DO ANYTHING.